si soplamos aire sobre una botella de
refresco por ejemplo va a ser un sonido
aquí tengo una botella y cuando soplo
suena así
y la pregunta es por qué hace ese sonido
y tiene que ver con algo que llamamos
ondas estacionarias
ondas
estacionarias o un concepto que se
relaciona mucho es el de resonancia
cómo funciona esto bueno vamos a verlo
aquí yo tengo este modelo de una lata de
refresco que tiene esta forma cilíndrica
y algo importante es que uno de los
extremos está cerrado este lado está
cerrado y lo quise indicar con este otro
tono aquí este es el fondo de la botella
de refresco que se encuentra de lado y
este otro lado de la lata está abierto
así que tenemos un lado abierto y otro
lado cerrado y adentro hay aire qué va a
pasar si yo soplo pues que este aire se
va a empezar a mover pero qué va a pasar
con esta molécula de aire que se
encuentra aquí en el fondo pues cuando
yo sople va a querer oscilar hacia
adelante y hacia atrás pero no va a
poder hacerlo ya que se encuentra con
esto cerrado con este lado de acá y
cuando trata de moverse golpea a este
lado cerrado y empieza a perder energía
de manera que aunque quiera moverse no
se va a poder
mucho a diferencia de lo que sucede en
este otro lado donde esta molécula se
puede mover todo lo que quiera puede
bailar aquí va a oscilar con gusto
adelante y hacia atrás y bueno no va a
oscilar tanto como lo estoy dibujando
aquí pero es para que se den una idea de
que en este lado las moléculas de aire
van a oscilar mucho más de lo que lo
hacen las moléculas aquí en el fondo y a
la mitad después las moléculas de aire
van a oscilar un poquito más pero no
tanto como aquí afuera algo intermedio y
para que visualicen mejor esto hice una
animación en donde se muestra que cuando
estoy moviendo las moléculas de aire las
moléculas del fondo casi no se mueven y
las moléculas en el lado abierto se
mueven mucho más y las moléculas en
medio pues se mueven un poquito más
aunque se mueven cada vez menos conforme
están más cerca del lado cerrado y es
así como estamos modelando esta
aunque si quitáramos o cortaremos esta
parte seguiríamos teniendo ondas
estacionarias y esto luciría algo así en
donde la lata estaría abierta en ambos
extremos este lado está abierto
y este otro lado también está abierto
por lo que ahora las moléculas de aire
que se encuentran de este lado se pueden
mover más las partículas de aire de este
lado también se van a mover como quieren
y resulta que si yo soplo aquí
imagínense que es una tubería de pvc y
tenemos los dos extremos abiertos
si yo soplo aquí voy a tener otra
resonancia tendremos otra onda
estacionaria y a la mitad
tendremos que estas moléculas se van a
quedar estacionarias estas de los
extremos se van a mover como quieran
pero las de enmedio no se van a mover
esto luce algo así en donde los extremos
oscilan como locos y lo que está en el
medio casi no se mueve y esta es una
onda estacionaria aunque realmente a mí
no me gusta ese nombre de onda
estacionaria me gusta más el nombre de
ondas danzantes ya que el aire se está
moviendo estas partículas se están
moviendo hacia adelante y hacia atrás en
estas x casi no se mueven
la mayor parte de las partículas de aire
se están moviendo pero le llaman ondas
estacionarias porque si ustedes
recuerdan de una onda se veía algo así
como que esto estuviera aquí comprimido
y esta región comprimida pareciera que
se estuviera moviendo hacia acá con
cierta velocidad por lo que ésta sería
una onda en movimiento en cambio con una
onda estacionaria se las voy a mostrar
otra vez pues aquí pareciera que
realmente la parte comprimida no se está
moviendo como que todo está rebotando
hacia adelante y hacia atrás así que
como describimos esto matemáticamente
que es la parte interesante lo que
podemos hacer es dibujar algunas líneas
vamos a dibujar unas líneas que simulen
en donde se encuentran las partículas
cuando están en estado de equilibrio y
esto de el estado en equilibrio es una
forma elegante de expresar esto tenemos
un tubo con los dos extremos abiertos
y es como está el aire si no nos metemos
con él si lo dejamos solito así que
dibujó estas líneas para indicar en
dónde quieren estar estas partículas de
aire de manera que si se desplazan lejos
de esta posición podamos darnos cuenta
de que tanto se desplazaron tenemos
nuestra tubería de pvc y es así como
lucen las partículas de aire antes de
que sople mos y cuando soplamos en la
tubería el aire luce así esta molécula
de aquí se desplazó hasta acá
esta se desplazó hasta acá esta otra
hasta acá y esta se desplazó un poquito
más esta de plano no se movió
esta se movió un poquito a la derecha
esta se movió un poquito más a la
derecha y está todavía un poco más hacia
la derecha también por lo que tendremos
diferentes desplazamientos en diferentes
puntos vamos a graficar esto voy a
dibujar un eje un eje horizontal y un
eje vertical también y esto lo voy a
hacer para conocer el desplazamiento
total esto es el desplazamiento
desplazamiento que tanto se desplazaron
las moléculas de aire y este eje de aquí
representa la posición de estas
partículas en el tubo en donde se
encuentran estas partículas en el tubo y
le voy a llamar x así que si gráfica mos
esto que vamos a tener bueno veo que
esta molécula de aire en este eje del
desplazamiento puede se desplazó
bastante y normalmente lo que está a la
izquierda va a ser negativo así que voy
a ponerla por acá tuvo un desplazamiento
muy grande este sino se desplazó este lo
vamos a dibujar en el eje porque
representa que no hubo ningún
desplazamiento aquí a la derecha también
tenemos un desplazamiento bastante
grande y hay todo tipo de rangos de
desplazamiento entre estos dos puntos
por lo que la gráfica va a verse algo
así
son menos
así y qué es esto es una onda
estacionaria y es lo que veríamos pero
no se van a quedar así esta molécula de
en medio casi no se va a mover pero esta
molécula de aquí va a tratar de regresar
hasta acá y va a rebotar va a moverse de
nuevo así por lo que si vemos esto
conforme pasa el tiempo veremos que esta
molécula va a tratar de regresar a su
estado de equilibrio y se va a estar
moviendo hacia adelante y hacia atrás va
a estarse moviendo hacia acá y en otro
punto del tiempo vamos a verla aquí y de
igual manera veremos que la mayoría de
las moléculas no se han desplazado tanto
como antes y si esperamos un poco más de
tiempo veremos que todo está en esta
línea no hay ningún desplazamiento
todo regresa a su posición de equilibrio
luego está se empieza a mover un poco
hacia la derecha
por lo que va a estar un poco a la
derecha de su posición de equilibrio y
eventualmente va a llegar hasta acá por
lo que veremos un comportamiento así si
vemos esta gráfica va a estar bailando
de arriba hacia abajo todo el camino
hacia arriba y después todo el camino
hacia abajo aunque esto no representa el
movimiento de las moléculas de aire las
moléculas de aire no se mueven hacia
arriba y hacia abajo solo se mueven de
izquierda a derecha y esta gráfica que
dibujamos representa el desplazamiento
que tienen hacia la derecha o hacia la
izquierda y a esto se le llama onda
estacionaria porque esto de aquí que
parece el pico de la onda no se está
moviendo hacia la derecha esto
simplemente está avanzando de arriba a
abajo y es por eso que yo les llamo
ondas bailarinas porque bailan de arriba
hacia abajo pero pues normalmente se les
conoce como ondas estacionarias esto se
mueve de arriba
y el lodo pues se queda aquí quietecito
en una onda en movimiento este nodo se
estaría moviendo hacia la derecha lo
mismo que los picos se estarían moviendo
a la derecha pero en este caso no es así
aquí no parece que se mueven así que es
por eso que se le llama onda
estacionaria y este punto en el centro
que no se mueve ya les comenté que tiene
un nombre en particular a esto se le
llama el nodo y estos extremos de acá
que se mueven con locura se les llama
anti nodos
así que tenemos que en los anti nodos
las moléculas se mueven con toda
libertad pero en el nodo no se mueven
para nada y este punto en la gráfica
permanece en cero y el truco aquí está
en como representamos esto
matemáticamente aquí lo representamos de
manera gráfica pero como lo
representamos matemáticamente vamos a
limpiar un poco esto la cuestión es
cuánto de una onda tenemos aquí qué
longitud de onda tendremos aquí bueno si
recordamos una longitud de onda completa
que voy a dibujar aquí aquí tengo dos
ejes que representan mi eje x y mi eje y
una longitud de onda va a ser cuando la
onda regresa hasta donde inicio desde un
punto en el ciclo hasta ese mismo punto
en el ciclo esto es una longitud de onda
completa cuánto es esto de una longitud
de onda
veamos comienza en el fondo y llega
hasta arriba pero aquí se detiene ya no
hay más así que esto será una longitud
de onda completa no es la mitad de una
longitud de onda es sólo la mitad de la
onda
si nosotros quisiéramos conocer qué
tanto es de la longitud de la onda con
base a la longitud de este tubo digamos
que este tubo tiene una longitud l para
esta primera onda diríamos que en l cabe
la mitad de la longitud de la onda la
mitad de la longitud de la onda cabe en
esta distancia por lo que l es igual
para esta primera onda estacionaria él
es igual a lambda entre 2
lo que significa que lambda es igual a 2
l así pues la lambda de esta onda es
igual a 2 l y esta es la frecuencia
fundamental o la longitud de onda
fundamental longitud de onda fundamental
y recibe este nombre especial porque es
lo que vamos a escuchar cuando soplamos
en este tubo pero no es la única
frecuencia o longitud de onda que
podemos encontrar tenemos que recordar
que estos extremos se van a mover como
locos estos van a ser los anti nodos
en este caso vamos a tener un nodo a la
mitad dos anti nodos en los extremos la
pregunta es que otras ondas
estacionarias podemos determinar debemos
tener un anti nodo aquí y otro anti nodo
en el otro extremo y vamos a tener un
nodo aquí aunque podemos tener varios
nodos en el medio no sólo uno
imaginemos que tenemos una onda
más o menos así tenemos un anti nodo en
este extremo otro anti nodo aquí ya que
en ambos extremos está abierto el tubo
por lo que los anti nodos se encontrarán
en estos extremos abiertos para que se
puedan mover y ahora aquí tengo dos
nodos en el medio cuánto es esto de una
longitud de onda bueno una longitud de
onda completa era esta onda azul y ahora
tenemos que la onda verde va de abajo
hasta arriba y de vuelta hasta abajo
esta es una longitud de onda completa
por lo que mi l para esta segunda onda
es una longitud de onda por lo que esta
es la segunda armónica esta frecuencia
casi no la escuchamos pero si
analizaremos las frecuencias aparecería
un poco de esta en este caso lambda es
igual a l y a esto le llamamos segunda
armónica aquí tenemos la
a 2 que es igual a l y es la segunda
armónica
habrá una tercera armónica no sé vamos a
ver qué tanto es posible sabemos que
tiene que haber anti nodos en los
extremos pero en lugar de tener uno o
dos nodos va a tener tres nudos así que
va a hacer
algo así sube por acá llega hasta arriba
baja
y vuelve a subir ahora aquí tengo un
anti nodo aquí tengo un anti nodo y
tengo uno dos tres nodos aquí en el
medio cuánto de una longitud de onda es
esto vamos a ver comienza aquí abajo va
hacia arriba baja pero no se queda aquí
continúa así que esto es más que una
longitud de onda así que esto es una y
media longitudes de onda hasta aquí fue
una longitud de onda llega hasta aquí y
además sigue otra mitad de longitud de
onda así que aquí l es igual a esta
distancia del tubo no cambia lo único
que ha cambiado es lo que cabe de una
longitud de onda en esta distancia
así que una y media longitudes de onda
es lo mismo que tener 3
longitudes de onda entre dos lo que
significa que lambda es igual a dos l
entre 3
por lo que en este caso lambda de 3 que
le vamos a llamar la tercera armónica
tercera armónica que es el tercer tipo
de onda que puede caber aquí es igual a
2 por l entre 3 y podemos continuar
haciendo esto cada vez que agregamos un
nodo más podemos tener una cuarta
armónica o una quinta armónica siempre y
cuando tengamos un anti nodo en un
extremo y otro anti nuevo en otro
extremo tendremos diferentes ondas
posibles si quisiéramos tener una
fórmula general para expresar estas
armónicas o estas ondas pues podemos
detectar un patrón aquí aquí tenemos dos
cl aquí tenemos el aquí tenemos dos l
entre tres resulta que la siguiente
sería 12 l entre 4 y la siguiente 12 l
entre 5 si quisiéramos expresar o
encontrar todas las posibles longitudes
de onda aquí le pongo n a estas
longitudes de onda va a ser igual a 2
por la longitud del tubo
/ n donde n es igual a 1234 y así
sucesivamente si aquí tengo que n es
igual a 1 me quedaría 2 l que es mi
frecuencia fundamental si n es igual a 2
voy a tener 2 entre 2 que es igual a l
por lo que voy a tener mi segunda
armónica si n es igual a 3 voy a tener 2
por el entre 3 que es mi tercera
armónica por lo que esta fórmula me da
todas las posibles longitudes de onda
para esta onda estacionaria y esto es
para un tubo que tiene ambos extremos
abiertos en el siguiente vídeo veremos
cómo trabajar con un tubo que tiene uno
de sus extremos cerrados